- [Announcer] Touchdown confirmed.
- [Narrator] On February 18th,
NASA's Mars 2020 mission
touched down on the red planet.
Since then, its Perseverance rover
and Ingenuity helicopter have
been exploring the terrain
and sending back never-before-seen images
and video of the martian surface.
- The Mars 2020 mission, Mars Perseverance
has had a string of firsts.
The first sounds from Mars.
(whooshing sound)
We can now hear the wind on another world.
More practically, it is the first test
of a new onboard navigation system
that gives a rover on
Mars greater independence
in how it can guide itself
around potential hazards.
- So we haven't just been driving.
We've actually been continuing some
of our tech demos.
- [Narrator] Jennifer Trosper
is NASA's Perseverance project manager.
She's been working on the mission
for the past seven years.
- We took on two
technology demonstrations.
One is an instrument called MOXIE
that actually uses the
carbon dioxide atmosphere
and then produces oxygen.
And then, of course, the
other technology demonstration
that we have been successful with
is showing that you can
fly helicopters on Mars.
- [Narrator] Now after
over 10 months on Mars,
what have we learned from Perseverance
and Ingenuity that we didn't know before?
And are we any closer to figuring out
if Mars has what NASA set out to find,
signs of ancient life?
- The only way to answer
it, NASA believes,
is to do what they're doing now,
go to another planet,
assess it thoroughly,
and then attempt to find the chemistry
and fossils that will
prove one way or another
whether there is life of
any sort we can recognize
on a planet other than our own.
- [Narrator] One of the most
important milestones took place
in mid-August when
Perseverance began collecting
rock core samples.
NASA's planning to retrieve
Perseverance's martian rock samples
with another spacecraft,
which is expected to
launch from Earth in 2026
and arrive at Mars in 2028.
- One of the big unanswered questions
that NASA faces in its search for life
and the collection of
these samples on Mars
is can we muster the will
and the funding, and the
engineering expertise
to actually bring these samples home?
Right now, there are plans
on the drawing board,
there are speeches, there are intentions
but it's a long time
between now and the 2030s
when these missions that
are being projected,
being talked about to
bring these things home.
- [Narrator] In April,
the Ingenuity helicopter
became the first craft to fly
in the atmosphere of another planet.
- This technology demonstration
was one for the history books.
This helicopter, which was
initially officially designed
to carry out just five flights
as a technology demonstration
has been flying all over,
it seems sometimes continuously.
- [Narrator] The next flights tested
the helicopter's ability
to move horizontally,
and it covered longer distances
in each subsequent flight.
Ingenuity has now flown 18 times.
- When we get over to the delta,
Ingenuity can again be used as a scout
to really point Perseverance
to the best places scientifically to go.
And if she's still living,
we have lots of opportunities
for scouting as we move
forward in the mission.
- [Narrator] NASA selected Jezero Crater
as Perseverance's landing site
because it gives the rover access
to a large stack of rocks
that sits at the end
of a dry river valley.
Based on satellite images,
scientists have theorized
that these rocks are made
of sediment deposited
by an ancient river
that flowed into a lake
roughly 3.5 billion years ago.
- So Jezero Crater is essentially,
if you're looking for signs
of ancient microbial life on Mars,
this is the place to go.
It's the location, location, location
for finding it because of
that delta that we see there.
- [Narrator] NASA
selected its landing site
because scientists have
long suspected the area
was once covered in water,
and therefore, had the potential
for the development of life as we know it.
- But they only could tell this
and target this in the
broadest outlines from orbit.
Now they have boots on the ground
or wheels if you prefer.
- [Announcer] (indistinct)
Indicates to deploy.
- [Narrator] Perseverance
landed more than a mile away
from the cliffs at the front of the delta
and started taking high-res pictures
to survey the distant rocks.
- We basically looked at
the different stratigraphy
that we saw,
and wanted to confirm that we were right,
that this really is a delta
with a river inflow, and it was deposited,
and there was a lake here.
And based on that,
we actually were able to confirm that.
- [Narrator] On October 7th,
NASA scientists published
the mission's first study
in the journal Science.
Based off those images,
the study found that for
potentially millions of years,
a river flowed into a lake
that filled Jezero Crater.
- We actually have a set of samples
that is very good for
the lower crater area.
We have four core samples.
We will have 30 that
we can return to Earth.
We'll collect more than that
and then we'll down select.
And that Earth return
is in the early 2030s.
- [Narrator] In December,
NASA scientists confirmed
yet another long-held suspicion,
that the martian bedrock
on which Perseverance rover
has been driving since February
likely formed from red hot magma.
- This was a big surprise to us.
Certainly not what we expected to find
that these are in fact volcanic rocks.
- [Narrator] This is Perseverance
project scientist Ken Farley
speaking at a recent
conference about the finding.
- This was completely unexpected
and we are struggling to
understand what it means.
But I will speculate.
So this appears to be a product
that was either intruded into
or erupted into the crater
or flowed in from outside.
But we don't know exactly
how that would work.
- [Narrator] Although it
landed on the martian surface
in February, Perseverance's
sample return mission
has only really just
started to get under way.
- The core samples are the hard evidence,
and I do mean the hard evidence
of something that we have
been speculating about
for the longest time.
We wanna have some tangible evidence,
something that we can
put under a microscope,
run genetic samples on.
Something that we can
prove beyond a shadow
of a doubt is not the
product of our creation
but is the product of a separate
creation on another world.
(pensive music)